yeah
all right hello everyone uh welcome back
from the lunch pick uh for this
afternoon I am very excited to be
introducing Cheval who will be
presenting on Dynamic graph algorithms
um this will be the first lecture as
part of a three-part series two today
one more tomorrow if I remember right on
uh Dynamic graph algorithms
um to introduce that's a problem
delighted that he has agreed to give
this uh presentation our Dr Paul's a
professor at the University of uh
Michigan where he's done over the last
20 years he's been a rather prolific
researcher in the area of dynamic craft
algorithms and optimization methods and
I think a lot of his work has really
kind of set some of the foundations that
underlie a lot of what this program is
about
um his uh Beyond his many many
Publications just getting faster
algorithms some of the tools and the
techniques he's developed and like
expander partitioning and the broad
Frameworks he's used to solve not just
like algorithmic problems but data
structure problems you can see their
influence all over nominal The Works
that that uh motivate
this entire program so without further
Ado uh thank you thatchup
thank you so much Aaron
um I'm honored to be here
um
like throughout my career I I listened
to a lot of Simon's video uh and super
happy to be here um
okay so today I want to talk about
Dynamic graph algorithms and first of
all what is what is what are dynamics
algorithm so the way you should think
about it is just the algorithm that
interact with the user you have an
algorithm and that is a user
and the USA will keep updating the input
and you keep
like reporting the new output after each
update
and to be more precise for this talk is
going to be about denim graph algorithm
and the setting will be like this so
first you will be given an input graph
g0 and you have time to pre-process it
and then for each time step
you will be given an update or a query
that's given to you online on the Fly
this update sequence is generated online
and then you just need to update your
data structure
or
answer the query right
so photo let me graph problem the update
usually are insertion or deletion of a
Nation or overtake sometimes
and the tasks are can be various
um you can answer the query like is the
graph connected or given any two node s
and t what's the distance but like you
can the task might be like to maintain a
big object like
um minimum spanning tree the graph
change you need to report how these
three change
after each update okay
and just to set up the basic terminology
um so I will use GI to denote the graph
after I update okay so think of this as
like a timeline right there are steps
and in the beginning you have g0 after
each update you get like the first
update you get G1 after the second
update you get G2 and so on
and the update sequence just I will just
use it to denote the sequence of updates
and queries
and for the update time this update time
is just a time needed to to to pre like
to process each step okay and we'll say
that the data structure or the algorithm
have t worst case at that time if every
step required most tea time
so for example if this is like a graph
that denotes the update time on each
step the worst case of that time
would be this much
okay
but sometimes
um it's more uh appropriate to
to like um to measure something called
amortized up the time
which is just at the time that is
it's like average time
it's the update times it's average over
time steps it's not average over like a
distribution or anything just average
over time steps so more precisely let's
like ask the key up care steps
if the total time that you text until
now
from the beginning is at most ketchy
then you set up the update time the
amortized at that time is at most t
so for example in this picture most of
the artists take this much time so the
amounts of that time is like this
in pre-processing time it's just a time
to pres process the g0
so this is not counted in the update
time it's just a time when you see
um the first graph
and
the last terminology
um is the fully Dynamic and partially
Dynamic so we set up the gra the
algorithm is fully Dynamic if they
handle both
um insertion and deletions otherwise
it's called partially Dynamic
incremental algorithm handle in
insertion decremental algorithm and the
deletions so that's kind of the standard
terms in in the area
and Okay so my goal uh in these two
lectures
um I hope to tell you three like General
templates on how to design Dynamic graph
algorithm
the first two is called the first two
are really classical and like many times
when you talk to Dynamic data structure
people like they just say just do that
and send that technique and I want to
tell you what exactly is Adam yeah
um the third one is vertexplicifier
which is a newer
um and but they are very
um uh generic and
the cable so everything is General it
just works for every problem
only the third template is specifically
to graph problem everything else is work
for every problem and for each of the
template I really want to give you like
a complete proof of at least some toy
concrete problem so that you really see
how it works from the beginning to the
end
Okay so before the first template let's
start with the warm-up one
um called rebuild so
so to talk about this template we need
to talk about some running sample of the
problem and we will look at
Dynamic smashing problem
okay
so let's talk about mashing what are
they well meshing is just a set of
destroyed edges
for example this red edges they don't
share any vertices so they are matching
the formal matching this is matching of
size two this one is a matching of size
three and it's a maximum one it's the
biggest matching so
and so given a graph I will use the G
mu of G
to denote the size of Maximum mashing
and in this Dynamic matching problem you
have a graph with n vertices right
um then there will be a sequence of edge
insertion and deletion is fully dynamic
the goal is just to maintain this number
approximation of mu of G
and how to solve this one
for any Dynamic data structure problem
what you can always do there is always a
trivial solution that is just to
recompute everything from scratch after
each update
and in this case an approximate machine
can be computed in linear time in number
of edges so number of edges over Epsilon
so you can do that
but I want to show you how to speed up
this from number of edges to number of
vertices okay so in update time okay
all right
so what's the algorithm
is going to be super simple
so this is the algorithm
so the algorithm is like this
what we do is just first you compute
approximate matching
approximate approximation of mu of G
just
by using static algorithm compute it
from scratch
and store it in new Tudor
okay
once you have computed
for the next
Epsilon muted tilde steps
you do not nothing
just return what you have computed from
before just wait and return this number
then once you have created this much
then you repeat go to the review step
compute it again and wait and recompute
so that's the algorithm
so why this is correct
um
so each update
whether it's Edge insertion or deletion
can change the size of the maximum
machine just by one One update one
insertion can increase
matching size by one deletion can
decrease like the MU of G by one
okay so with this in mind then you have
what
you have that I claim that like mu of G
and mu 2 need to be like within one plus
if so infected at all time
and the reason is like
after review step just right after the
review step you have that okay mu of G
is within one plus it's one of mutilda
but then you wait you wait for Epsilon
further updates
but then mu of G can change by this much
right
and which means what it means that at
any time mu of G and mutual are just
within one plus Epsilon Factor
so okay so mutida is always
one plus Epsilon
approximation of mu of G
so that's the that's the correct
algorithm
so what's left is just to analyze the
update time I claim that this at that
time is n instead of number of edges
and okay let's analyze it
so
the update times look like like this the
timelines look like this so you rebuild
you spend a lot of time and you wait and
do nothing and rebuild and wait right
so
so the update times if you unlock if you
want to just compute armor ties at that
time
you just need to kind of basically
for each of this phase
that you wait
you just
compute
um the time that you rebuild
amortized over this length of the face
so the size of the size of a graph
over me of G
and I claim that this is just n
and why is that and if this is 2D we're
done okay
so why is that well
um
explain that
number of edges is at most mu of G times
2N at most okay
so to see this you can look at for
example
look at any maximum matching let's call
it m star
M size of size mu of G
like this this is a mu M Star
and now after that
every age
in the graph
must be incident to some M Star ages in
M Star so this one
share some vertices with the blue edge
every Edge is incident to M Star
because otherwise if you have an another
Edge that is not incident to M Star you
could have add that to your matching and
you get a bigger matching
okay
so note this in mind every Edge is
incident to M Star
so then just consider
this scenario
suppose you delete one Edge in M Star
let's delete this Edge
okay that would remove
Atmos to n edges in the graph
together with it
because if you I if I remove this guy
then this Edge would be removed and I
this would remove it so I would remove
like a degree of U plus degree of B
which is 2N at most
okay
and then if I repeat this formula of G
time I repeat
this for every M Star edges
then there's no edges left in the graph
so it means that
um
the total number of edges that you
remove
is the most new
G times 2N so that
e of G is the most 2G new g e of G is
equals mu G times 2N
because of this we get that this thing
is indeed at most n
over Epsilon Square
and that's it you we get an algorithm
with n amortized at that time
okay
so just to recap what we really what we
what we just seen
it's really like it yes
so the question is
um whether we actually return just like
one plus Epsilon approximation
so like
so you say that the time to recompute
the match increase the number
yeah right is this like an unperception
approximate algorithm to compute the
foreign yes
that you can compute from scratch
any like an approximate attaching in
linear time
in M over X
Okay so
let's reflect and what we have seen is
is General right so actually if you are
given actually any algorithm
that says let's say it can handle how
many updates
and it it has rebuild time TB and worst
case at that time tu
then I claim that
we can we just show how to get another
algorithm a prime that can handle
infinite
like infinitely many seek updates such
that the amortized at that time is TB
over L plus tu
because like what you do is just like
for each fish of length L you rebuild
and then you update with this running
update time to you
and the amortize up that time per face
is just t b over l
for our case we get like this thing
Dynamic matching in N amortized time
where L is like L is Epsilon mu
TB is m e of G over Epsilon and Tu is
just one o of one
just by plugging this thing you get in
amortize at that time
it's pretty simple
and um
next so you see that one thing that is
not really like a certifying is that you
get amortized at that time so let's
let's try to improve this a bit to make
it worse case
time you could just say amortize the
study from the beginning right
one more time starting from the
beginning
we might
uh
you mean this one
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah Tu can be relaxed
if
T so the question is if you repeat
request to you by amortize uh that time
from the beginning
um you could have get this thing as well
yeah
right
okay
Okay so
and okay well next uh I will just show
you how to improve this case
so that is like the first template that
we're going to look at which is with you
in the background this is a kind of
develop like basically
by like
any paper the classic paper like
primarily by Michael and and by Monica
so like let's see how what it is exactly
um
so so recorded we have this reduction
right
given an algorithm that can handle L
updates with some review time and worst
case of that time you get this amortized
at that time using this kind of idea
um let me simplify the picture a bit
like this is still like update time
um I'm just gonna write it like easier
so what I do is now I just want to worst
case at that time is I want to remove
this peak
yeah
okay
and first the first step is I will show
you an algorithm that actually is
correct only half
of the time only is correctly on half of
the update sequence not the whole thing
but you see that this is very easy to
fix to be to be correct at all steps
okay let's let's look at the algorithm
the algorithm a domain Prime with voice
chest after time is like this
so
so look at each face of length L like
before
I would divide each face of length l
into three periods
the red yellow and green one
these period is like this so
the first l04 updates steps in the in
the face
is for rebuild okay
and
what we would do is like we if the
starting
time of the face is t0
we will look at the graph at time t 0
gt0 and try to rebuild the whole data
structure for gt0
okay but
the point is that now
instead of spending
this whole Review Time on one step
you try to distribute the work evenly um
on the period
so you have like
L over four steps
you just kind of for each step you spend
TB over L4
amount of time once you spend this much
work you stop wait for the next update
and go to the and then spend more time
and wait for next update and spend more
time
if your total review time is TB
after
hour for updates you will finish
rebuilding
okay
and for during this period you will just
ignore all the updates so once you are
finished you build the data structure
for the graph in the past
because there are some updates given to
you already
so that's why you you need the next
period which is a cash up period
that is for the next our four steps
want me to do it's like the yellow one
you just feed two updates
for each step instead of
One Step you get one update you just
feed two update to your data structure
from the past
try to be like double speed okay
and once you are done with like
you were like working at Double speed
during this yellow period when you're
done then you would have catch up
without update you have seen so far
okay
and then after that that's when you kind
of can be active so for the next uh hour
two steps in the last hour Two Step In
the period in the face now your data
structure is up to date
so you can feed the update normally
like one update per step that's the
structure and you will get correct uh
answer during this period
so you see that like the green part here
you'll be correct
the red and yellow part you are not
quite correct you don't have a a correct
answer for the current update
um the question is can we do this with
with our knowledge of L ahead of time
uh I am not sure yeah
same possible I don't know this right
now
okay okay
so but you see that indeed the update
time the worst case of that time now is
really like the same
CB or L plus tu
you have we had amortized one before now
we have one
for Supply sequence so let's fix this
okay let's try to be correct at Austin
so trick is simple
uh let's try to make two instance of a
doubling Prime
so a different prime one and a 11 Prime
2. make two copy of the data structure
this increase the update time by Factor
two
and you try to schedule them
so that
at every time step
um one of them is correct
so if admin primer is like this
then you just kind of
make this period shift it like this
and now
um at every time step
um one of them must be correct
so note that like because
for this second one you have this guy
which is correct from the beginning so
you would need to like spend
pre-processing time but the
pre-processing time at time step 0
doesn't count in the update time so
that's fine
okay
so just to conclude
um what we have right
um we have this one that is if you have
an algorithm that can handle L updates
with some review time and worst case at
that time then you get another algorithm
that can handle any
length of update
with tbol plus t u worst case update
time
and that's how we get
simple
Dynamic meshing algorithm with n
worst case update time
and you can try to think about this that
it's easy to improve this and to just
max degree of G
um
so
there's some hint here but I make it
hard to read
okay
so okay
yeah so this is much better if the graph
is fast
okay so let's go to the next template
which is called batching
yes can I ask what the best runtime is
yeah so the question is like what's the
best update time for OnePlus it's not
matching right now
the answer is something like
n to the one minus sum
function of Epsilon
so it's strictly below linear
uh but by a tiny bit
good very good question so
if you want to Output the meshing
um basically this is still the
essentially the best one
there is some algorithm that actually
the running time is root m
um actually this thing can be replaced
by root M as well so if you want to
Output meshing itself
n or root m is like the best one
okay
next one
um bashing
um this is used by many many works one
of them like the first one I saw is like
the one by Mikhail but there might be
some some earlier one I'm not sure
but they did it for a different problem
with this problem thanks yeah
oh yeah sorry yes yes you're right right
right
okay good
I think
okay okay uh so
to tell you about this idea I will show
you another toy problem which is a real
problem actually
um
decremental connectivity
so
in this problem
um you have a graph with n vertices and
M edges
it's a sequence of H
deletion only
that's why we call it decremental
let's say for Simplicity I just want to
check if the graph is connected the
whole graph is connected or not at all
time
simple algorithm is just to be do it
from scratch BFS and spend linear time M
time per update
I will show you a simple algorithm that
like uh stands into the two thirds worst
case at that time
this is far from the best known
algorithm but um
but it it gives you like it's a nice one
to tell you the idea
okay okay
so to get to this algorithm
what we'll look at is to look at
one batch version of the problem
so one batch what is the setting for one
batch algorithm
um which is you often easily to this
easier to design
you have a graph
and then
the update is just a single
set of edges
call it d a single batch of updates The
Edge deletion
and it can handle only this single batch
no no more like nothing else just single
batch
after this you just need to answer one
thing that is after you delete this set
of edge but I think this single dash one
called G Prime
G Prime is like G minus D is this graph
updated graph still connected
so there is only one batch that you need
to handle
and what I will show soon is that there
is this one batch algorithm
such that the initialization time is
almost linear
and update time is something like this
Square
and let's assume this for a bit
and let's see a simple way to get from
this thing to
the dynamic algorithm such that
it has this worst case at that time
the one that handles sequence of update
instead of one batch
okay so let's see the reduction is
simple
a simple idea is that just
if you want to handle an update sequence
but you have only one batch algorithm on
your hand
let's say what what can we do well
given the eyes update in the sequence
what I will do is just
create a bash which is just the first up
I update from the beginning until the
eighth steps
this is one one batch and feed it to to
your batch algorithm one batch algorithm
this would take like I Square time
because uh
um our algorithm has this update time
okay offset d square
okay
so just from this simple idea what we
get now is that we get some algorithms
such that
let's say I want to handle it can handle
L updates
and the review time is
initialization time is just
linear
but the update time
for each time it says at most L Square
just
to handle that the ice update just
create one batch give it to the one bash
algorithm
for the next one just kind of revert
everything
create a batch of size I plus one
give it to one batch algorithm and so on
okay
and from from this one you will get an
algorithm with this running time huh
we'll just we have this black box
reduction right
um
given this kind of algorithm
you get an algorithm with worst case at
that time with TB over L plus tu
and
by plugging this thing in you get an
algorithm with mol plus L Square update
time choosing the right L which is m to
the one third you get M 0 2 3. update
time algorithm
yes
the assumption
data structure is like rewindable that
uh yeah wish yeah like the question is
whether we can maybe assume that the
data structure is rewardable and the
answer is like we we can assume this
with our loss optionality
you can there's a techniques called
persistence
because
if you could use Randomness though with
this isn't more concerning
it doesn't use Randomness at all yeah
yeah if the data structure hadn't used
Randomness okay that would have caused
issues for rewindability yeah that then
I did yes yes
so let's see how to build this one batch
algorithm the a dash thing okay
so you'll see that like it's quite
simple to design one dash algorithm
okay and the idea is this
you have a graph
initially you just compute the spanning
tree of a graph
then you are given an update Dash
set D of D of the escalation
so you just kind of delete some edges
some of the edges is like you delete
some three edges here
some deletion is not three edges
so that deletion will divide like kind
of split your spanning tree in the
beginning into like some components
uh
T1 up to d t d Prime okay
P Prime is like kind of Atmos D plus one
so you get this component
from your spanning tree
and
our goal
it will suffice to just check basically
between every pair of this component
whether there is some none tree Edge
that could reconnect this component
together
if you can then you're done right
basically you look at this component and
you kind of kind of want to know whether
there is some non-free Edge reconnecting
this thing this thing or this thing
if you can check all this you're done
so let's let's see how to do that
and to do that we would need some basic
Tools in graph data structure which is
Euler tour and basic tool in data
structure in general which is
a 2d range query
let's see
so
the first one which is 2D range query is
something that I would just
tell you that it exists and I assume it
it's simple to implement using some
range 3 but okay so this problem is like
this you have like a set of points into
the p
okay and you can basically
insert and or delete a point into the
set in like log Square time
and then you can also query which is you
query some rectangle like this
so you just specify like the end point
of the rectangle
and there's given the query it will
answer you with like return you some
point in the in the range
in lock time
so that's 2D range query
how about Euler tour
this is just a way to represent any tree
as a path
so let's see some examples so suppose
that you have these three
consider like
when you kind of just walk
around a tree
and then like just write down which
which node you have seen from this walk
from these two so you have seen one two
three four five and then four three six
seven six three two one
so that's that's all the two of the tree
so that's like now it's like given a
trade you can kind of represent it as
like some
essentially like some sequence which is
like a path basically
and for any Edge in the tree
it will correspond to two H in Euler
tour of the tree for example here this
Edge
would correspond to like two things here
because
you will kind of
see this Edge twice in the tool
so these are like two basic things let's
see how to use it right
okay
so now the algorithm the one bash
algorithm
that we will really Implement is like
this
um
initial to initialize just compute some
spanning tree the green thing here
there will be some none tree H the
yellow one in the tree
computer spanning tree
and computer Euler tool of that tree
just walk along this thing
and you get some Euler tour here
I write it here and write it here too
kind of to create some 2D space
okay
so now the next important step is this
for every nun3h
will be let's say 93X digit the purple
one here
foreign
corresponding to this Edge
so where do I add it well
so one and three here I just add like
one
and three
just look at like where where is the
first place that one exist one appears
is here where is the first place that
three appears it's here that's what
that's what I mean by mean rank like the
first place that one occur in the first
place the three ocher is here
you just put the point here
and this is another one
this one corresponds to these two guys
now the other three edges none three
edges this two and these two is which is
this one
so just put
just put this like 93 edges into the
point
into the space 2D space
so that's the pre-processing
now
what we had next we are given one batch
of update the set d
so what we do
you get some deletion let's say this
thing and this thing okay
what I would do is this
first of all if I delete some 938 yeah
I would need to delete the corresponding
point from this space
just do that okay
that can be done in D time D poly lock
time
next
when I delete a three Edge
is 3H from two to three
that actually partitioned the interval
into parts right let's say I delete an H
from two to three so that I cut it here
and I cut it three yeah so I get this
into intervals
do it like vertically and horizontally
okay
so this is like I get these intervals
the number of interval is something like
o of T because the Rd deletion
now I claim that all you need to do from
here
it's just
kind of I get kind of d by D kind of day
by day grid here
so I just
kind of query each of this part
whether there is a point or not
and you should be able to convince
yourself that just by querying this
thing
can check it means that you can check
whether that is a non-3 h between any
like uh two component of the trees
algorithm
okay and the running time initialization
time is just spending Tree on a tour put
initialize the the 2D range which is
linear time
how about this part these two parts
it's just the time but the last step
which is to query this Square Mini
like rectangle that takes you this
Square time
so that's why the update time is d
square
so that's what we get
we get an algorithm with initialized one
batch algorithm with linear
initialization time update time d square
and just by previous reduction that we
saw we get
decremental connectivity with n to the
two third worst case of that time
and you see this is generic if you have
if you would have this thing to if you
improve this and you could actually
um you would get
just try and rearrange like just by
balancing you get better update time
and
exercise again uh
and try to just make sure that you
understand this um
do it offline
suppose instead that you you have two
batch algorithm
okay
so
this algorithm that okay start you have
start with the graph then there is a
first Dash D1 given to you
and then it can handle yet another batch
B2
oh you need to and then you shake
whether the graph after the after this
deleting D1 and D2 whether it's
connected or not
if you uh suppose you have an algorithm
that okay the first like initialization
time is still linear
the time to take care of the first batch
is linear in the size of the first batch
and the time for the second batch is
linear in the size of the second batch
not the first batch
if you think of this as D1 is like into
the two third
and
D2 here is m to the one third
so the second batch is smaller than the
first one
if you have this algorithm uh just maybe
try to convince yourself
that
you could use the idea you have seen to
get
into the one third worst case of that
time algorithm
and if you get like K bash algorithm
then it will just improve
when reminders that like there are
actually like
several algorithms in literature that
actually can handle care batch and
usually when you can handle two batch
you can handle okay Bash
but not for one bash usually one bash is
really easier than two batch
for example the idea that we have seen
today
it's not clear how to Adrenalize it to
make it to work with two batch because
once you have kind of delete your like
once you have
partition the the 2D range algorithm
into like these Square mini grids
how to handle the second batch
not clear
why is
it sorry I don't quite
doesn't work for insertions
oh so
exercise it works for inflation yes yes
yeah you can
try to see why actually it works for
Insertion I just said this is for
deletion because
just for Simplicity in presenting
good
question
all right
intuition of why you have okay badge I
mean you can fly
an example where somehow it's natural or
oh I see
well
if you have an algorithm with that
handle came back
um I'm sorry I'm not sure I get your
question
if you had one but I'm saying why would
you I mean like some natural condition
of you have some decreasing batch sizes
that will help you yes yes yes like
so
it was the inclusion to get this running
time
you mean well okay so
roughly speaking if you have an
algorithm with care fashion that can
Okay match updates
yeah you would create like to get this
kind of algorithm you would
the first step would be the biggest one
the second batch would be like smaller
by and the one okay Factor this but that
is even smaller and so on and you would
just schedule it so that
um
you get this kind of thing yeah
thank you if you're trying to ask the
same question like what's a a good
exercise problem to think about where
designing a batch algorithm is uh
natural
yeah
um
what's the natural algorithm that you
can get okay good exercise thank you for
giving exercise yes
I yeah I don't have that in mind
um the one that I know that actually
handle care Bash
like the problem the problem that use
this thing is is to prune expander
extended pruning problem but that might
not be the simplest one yeah
we have a zoo if anyone picks up one
later
action
so
that's this
second
um
[Music]
so we have 10 minutes before the break
the break
so I will use this to talk about
something before the third template
let me tell you a bit about vertex
specifier
and this is something that actually is
extensively studied in approximation in
fpt specifically kernelization
um
and it has really nice connection to
Dynamic graph
so um what are they well Vertex
specifier or people also call it
mimicking Networks
um the general setting is like this
let's say you have a graph a big huge
graph
then you have like a small set of
terminal
s
what we want to Output is a small graph
Ash
that contains like the terminals at
least
but
the size of the graph as here should be
like upsized proportion to to the
terminal side
so it's kind of trained the graph
diametrically
and yet
should preserve basically
information like useful information
in the graph that is related to the
terminals
and when Ash preserve information about
G related to h i I kind of want to write
like ash approximate G
with respect to to the terminal set is
and we also call this like of specify of
G with respect to s
so
this is like a very nice thing
um kind of
compression
and let me tell you about like at least
I will not tell you how to construct
this is not it's not complex but that is
even simpler thing but
um one example is like this
vertex specifier for shortest path
which is based on the work by
McCain Brewery
you can throw that for any number okay
parameter k
they X is a graph the Spotify h
such that the size of the number of
edges in Edge is just something like s
time into the 1 over k
so close to the size of the terminal
and
but what we get is like it preserves
useful information about s that is for
every pair
smt that are terminal
the distance
between s and t sorry
let's say this before any pair u and v
in the terminal the distance between u
and v in the specifier and in the
original graph are the same
up to
care Factor
so that so this kind of thing exists
and I would tell you
um how to construct vertex specifier for
like a different problem
um which is called Let It call mean Max
path
um it has
okay
so
what is min max path um it has a close
connection to minimum spanning tree it's
like just a simple thing so
let's say that um I have this simple
graph yeah
an st min max path
it's just a path from s to T
that has minimum max max weight
and
for example
in this graph
the min max path from s to T is this
path
because it has smaller minimum weight
smaller maximum weight in the path and
min max of St is seven here
if you go this way the min max is is
nine
okay
so this is something that like a natural
and actually
um
the key point about this min max path is
that if you want information about
midnight min max path you can specify
the graph into a tree
and what is set three minimum spending
tree
so minimum spending three actually
preserves
or min max path
okay
so before we take a break I want to tell
you about this and we continue after the
break so
um let's say that
you have a graph and let's say t is your
minimum spending tree
and let's let me denote like
a path
from s to T in in the tree it's just a
unique path from SCT in the tree
ptst is a unique path from s to T
if you have this minimum spin 3 in the
graph
I claim that
a unique path from s to T like this one
entry
is itself
St min max path
and
um
why is that because let's assume for
contradiction that it's not right
but they would access another path let's
call it P Prime that go from s to T
such that
um two thing happens
um if you look at
the maximum weight in this path from
from s to T in the tree
the maximum edge with a maximum width is
e Max
the weight here let's say nine
must be more than the width of
everything in this path the the purple
part
because we assume that this
this three is not the this path is not a
min max path so that is a better one
the purple one so this way here
are all smaller than nine
if there is a path then you have you can
actually construct
a smaller tree which is well just maybe
like include this Edge and delete Emax
from the from the tree you get a tree
that is small with smaller weight
okay
so that's why uh minimum time tree
really preserve all min max path
so remember this and um I will like next
I will show how to actually construct
vertex specifier
from min max path uh after the break
thanks
thank you any questions
I've been waiting
for passing off the microphone
you mentioned rewinding earlier what
what is that
oh so
the question is what is rewarding
rewarding just means like
let's say you have some algorithm and
the algorithm proceed like do something
up to some point and you just want to
revert all of the configuration of the
algorithm back to some point of time in
the past that's rewinding and
in the discussion we just say that you
can assume that you can always do this
for any data structure
using persistence
any more questions
well it's a it's a great question I just
received this email from Simon's the T
time starts at 3 pm and now you say here
that our
coffee break well it's of course not the
same as T but that's from 2323 but is
there any kind of synchronicity here or
we will have a break from 2 30 to 3 and
I look forward to seeing what's outside
the door
times with the workshops but I can look
into it and thank you
it's the other questions
that's maybe that's a good segue so so
it's a coffee break now while we're
taking a break for the next half hour
I'll see you all back in here at three
o'clock thank you